whenever we plan an add-on we always
want to take the player somewhere new a
new place with new stories and new
experiences far Harbor is the largest
landmass we've ever made for an add-on
it's a high-level area full of mystery
and danger and a new conflict between
the townspeople the children of Adam in
the sense so we decided to go to Maine
mostly because we wanted to extend the
sort of New England feel that we hadn't
fallout but take a place that was more
rugged and like a harsher terrain and
then build on that make something that
was sort of a feral experience most of
the town is actually destroyed and the
inhabitants live on the very edge of the
town on a dock so you first arrive to
this island and it's a huge island
you're not sure where to go and he
pointed to old Longfellow who's this
salty fisherman you meet in an inn this
is now your guide to the island I got
better things moving guide fools to the
dead when we looked at making the people
who live in pharr Harbor we thought
about how would people survive in this
horrible radiated mist and we knew
before all this would have happened they
would have been fishermen they survived
up here on their own and could take care
of themselves so that's sort of
reflected in their clothing and then the
armor that they where they have large
meat hooks for melee weapons and we
added a harpoon gun that's really
powerful and does a lot of damage we
added a new lever action hunting rifle
it's very powerful and has a really cool
rate of fire we added a whole new combat
armor at the very top level called the
marine combat arm it's the best armor
you can get short of wearing the power
armor so we focused on looking at some
of the the natural creatures and what
would become of them as they evolve in
this wilderness so we added something
called the gulp or this sort of mutated
salamander creature we have the angler
who's through his physiology absorbs the
fugg and then spits it at the player in
flaming fireballs we also have a fog
crawler it's sort of like a really large
and we had a lot of new creatures like
this that would fit in the ecology of
this new location one of the big things
we wanted to explore with sense and for
harbor is this idea what does it mean if
I think I've replaced someone I could be
a human being I could be a synth all of
these feelings could be genuine or they
could all be a lie that someone else has
put into my head and I'm just carrying
out some unknown purpose we really liked
the experience of the glowing sea in the
base gaming juju radiated landscape high
level area you find the turn of Adam
there as well we wanted to go into the
question of who are they really what
brings someone into a cult with a belief
that the atomic bomb is somehow a great
thing when we were planning for harbor
we knew we wanted there to be a lot of
different endings or different different
ways of resolving the conflicts between
the groups and that each group would
have a conflict not only one that a
conflict that encompasses the whole
island but different conflicts within
the groups themselves we hope you enjoy
far harbour and we can't wait to see
what you discover and what choices you
make
you